es wurde jetzt eine weitere wirklich
unfassbare eigenschaft vom
wahrscheinlichen zahlreichen schwarzen
löchern aufgedeckt aber erst mal ist das
spezielle schwarze loch das jetzt
vermessen werden konnte etwas ganz
besonderes denn es dreht sich fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit und stößt damit an
die grenzen der einsteinschen
relativitätstheorie heißt das etwa dass
es tatsächlich sogar das ganze universum
mitreißen könnte krieg zum science
fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierende videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen
ein super spannendes thema das ihr euch
über die web community gewünscht habt
die im dank dafür
auf genau zwei methoden können
forschungsteams weltweit derzeit
zurückgreifen um schwarze löcher zu
vermessen spannend ist zum einen die
masse und zum anderen eben die
rotationsgeschwindigkeit des jeweiligen
schwarzen loch ist diese drehrad ist
eine dimension slower einheit und kann
von null bis zu einem maximalwert von
einst reichen
ein internationales forschungsteam hat
jetzt ein schwarzes loch untersucht das
einen unglaublichen wert von 0,9
erreicht dazu einer der beteiligten
wissenschaftler so die ba
wenn schwarze löcher entstehen sind
masse und spinnen rate zwei
eigenschaften die sie charakterisieren
dabei kann die masse deutlich einfacher
gemessen werden als die rotationen da
die masse aufgrund der schwerkraft einen
großen einfluss auf die entstehung eines
schwarzen lochs hat die durchgeführten
messungen der spinrath sind also ein
voller erfolg für die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ausschlaggebend dabei waren die
röntgenstrahlen die das objekt aus
sendet diese entstehen dadurch glas ist
gas und staub verschluckt durch die
messung dieser strahlung gelang es dem
astronomie team die rotation rate mit
dem unglaublichen wert von 0,9 bestimmt
das objekt wurde übrigens bereits vor
zwei jahren von indiens erstem satellit
namens astro sand aufgespült konkret
befindet sich das schwarze loch in dem
doppelsternsystem 416 30 47 das schwarze
loch dreht sich also fast in
lichtgeschwindigkeit diese liegt bei 299
millionen 792 1458 meter pro sekunde und
somit es ist tatsächlich an den grenzen
der relativitätstheorie von albert
einstein dann nach einsteins theorie
führt ein schnell rotieren des schwarzes
loch dazu
sich der raum selbst dreht physikalisch
gesehen bedingungen solche schwarze
löcher durch ihre enorme gravitation
eine entsprechend große veränderung der
geometrische struktur von raum und zeit
also der sogenannten raumzeit kommen
doch die raumzeit wird vereinfacht
gesagt nicht durch das schwarze loch
bekommt es reißt sie sogar aufgrund
seiner rotation mit konkret bedeutet das
also alle objekte um das schwarze loch
werden mit gedreht denn auch die
raumzeit selbst dreht sich mit dass
jetzt vermessen objekt gehört übrigens
zu den einigen wenigen schwarzen löchern
bei denen bislang eine solch hohe
rotationsgeschwindigkeit nachgewiesen
werden konnte also ein paar hat man
jetzt schon gefunden aber auch deswegen
ist das forschungsteam nämlich so
dermaßen die fläche von diesem ergebnis
kommt die studie allerdings noch in
keinem wissenschaftlichen fachmagazin
veröffentlicht dies soll jedoch
demnächst im fachblatt the astrophysical
journal passieren auch wenn wir immer
mehr zu den schwarzen löchern selbst
erfahren stellen sie uns doch im großen
und ganzen noch vor riesige rätsel
durch den chandra satelliten
beispielsweise der an röntgenteleskop am
start hat konnte die nasa bereits vor
einiger zeit spannende erkenntnisse zu
schwarzen löchern sammeln die sich
derart schnell drehen fest steht alles
was ihnen zu nahe kommt wird verschluckt
vorher aber sammelt sich die materie in
der sogenannten akkretionsscheibe einer
schnell rotierenden scheibe und genau
diese akkretionsscheibe skis gigantische
materie strahlen aus vielen schwarzen
löchern heraus senkrecht nach oben und
nach unten ins all
und das sind die sogenannten jets die
man sich tatsächlich vorstellen kann wie
fontänen forschungsteams vermuten schon
seit längerem dass die jets wohl aus
nickel und eisen bestehen und mit
unglaublichen 200.000 kilometern pro
sekunde ins all schießen
das sind zwei drittel der
lichtgeschwindigkeit forschungsteams
wissen immer noch nicht genau wie diese
sogenannten jets entstehen
doch nach auswertung der chandra daten
ist die energie solcher jets wohl zum
einen von der masse und ebenso anderen
vom drehmoment des schwarzen lochs
abhängig also davon wie schnell sich
dieses schwarze loch dreht und hiermit
schließt sich eben der kreis denn die
auswertung von chandra daten legt nahe
dass sich solche schwarzen löcher wohl
nach ihrer maximalen geschwindigkeit
drehen müssen also würde dieses drehen
mit fast lichtgeschwindigkeit auf ganz
viele schwarze löcher zu treffen
solche detaillierten untersuchung zu
schwarzen löchern bewährten
forschungsteams weltweit übrigens als
besonders wichtig da sich somit
grundlegende theorien zum universum
überprüfen und testen lassen
es ist schon wahnsinn was wir immer
wieder für grundlegende erkenntnisse
über das weltall erfahren und täglich
kommen neue hinzu und wir bei pixum hier
berichten darüber wenn er kein video
verpassen wollt dann abonniert auf den
englischen kanal einfach hier
draufklicken da gibt es immer wieder
videopremieren so und jetzt kommt der
hammer von unterwegs wir machen einen
livestream zur feier von zehn jahren
krieg summe von 500.000 abonnenten und
mit einem thema das uns in den letzten
wochen sehr beschäftigt hat aliens dazu
gibt es nämlich neue sensationelle
erkenntnisse und wenn er den livestream
nicht verpassen wollt dann genau hierhin
klicken der gibt ihn also bis dann
bleibt dran